This video was made possible by Skillshare.
Learn for free for two months by being one
of the first 1000 to sign up at skl.sh/wendover9.
The United States Navy is traditionally known
for its military might.
It is, by far, the largest and potentially
most capable Navy in the world thanks to its
innumerable aircraft carriers, destroyers,
and submarines.
But, beyond those, and beyond all the cruisers
and patrol boats and other combat ships, there
are two more that lurk in the shadows of the
490 ship fleet—the USNS Mercy and Comfort.
These are America’s hospital ships.
Hospital ships are more or less a forgotten
relic of a time when wars were far deadlier
and the world was far larger.
During those times, when fighting a war abroad,
just like today, one had to consider where
casualties would go, but unlike today, there
were no capabilities to quickly fly injured
personnel away from a battlefield.
One had to treat close to the conflict and
for that, the most viable option was often
to bring a hospital-ship to the fight.
These ships were once so significant that,
when nations came together to write the Geneva
Conventions, defining the rules of war, hospital
ships were a significant focus.
They specifically denote these as any that
specifically and solely work to assist the
wounded or sick, with the important distinction
that they cannot carry any arms or ammunition.
These ships also must be painted white with
red crosses to identify themselves, but assuming
these requirements are met, they are officially
classed as a hospital ship.
Those with this classification cannot, under
the Geneva Conventions, be attacked or fired
upon.
This was all plenty useful at the time the
Geneva Conventions were signed, but today,
land-based warfare is increasingly obsolete,
and it just doesn’t make sense to float
a hospital to a conflict zone when field hospitals
are more capable, and medical evacuation is
easy.
That’s why only eight nations’ navies
still include hospital ships.
Most of these are rather small and primarily
deployed for humanitarian purposes, but the
US’ two hospital ships, meanwhile, are massive.
They’re the size of cruise ships and comparable
in capability to the largest land-based hospitals.
Each holds 1,000 hospital beds including 80
intensive care beds.
In comparison, the entire state of Maine has
1,061 total and 64 ICU beds.
To have an entire state’s worth of medical
facilities available anywhere in the world
is an immensely useful strategic power, but
not entirely for the purpose of actually treating
US soldiers.
Within the military, the Comfort and Mercy
are officially classified as, “flexible
deterrent options.”
That's to say, they’re an option for, “show
of force.”
In wartime, sending a ship with capacity for
a thousand patients sends a message that the
US is willing to accept an immense amount
of casualties.
That may or may not be true, but the message
is there.
In peacetime, parading a hospital ship around
the world for humanitarian missions both fosters
good will for the US military, and also shows
countries the capabilities of the US’ military
health system.
The effectiveness of these ships as “flexible
deterrent options” could be debatable, but
in the military’s mind, this is the purpose
behind these ships.
They’re an option for deterrence or escalation.
That’s part of the reason why they’ve
seen so little deployment to combat zones.
That’s just not the primary purpose.
Each ship has only seen one deployment primarily
treating casualties of war—the Mercy to
Operation Desert Shield and Storm in 1990,
and the Comfort to the Iraq War in 2002.
For the rest of their 30 year histories, they
have spent their time deployed on humanitarian
missions to disasters or impoverished nations,
or in reduced operating status at their home
ports in San Diego and Norfolk.
While during active service the Mercy houses
well over 1,000 crew, most of its time is
spent in port, in that reduced operating status.
At such times, the massive ships will house
just 70 crew members who will keep it ready
to go at a moment’s notice.
By the nature of their service, expediency
of deployment is key.
Therefore, they’re designed so that they
can go from reduced operating status to leaving
San Diego or Norfolk in just five days.
But while they can leave quickly, that doesn’t
mean they can necessarily get to their destination
quickly.
The Mercy and Comfort are both converted oil
tankers that originally launched in 1975 and
1976, respectively.
Oil tankers are not designed for speed, as
it’s just not necessary, so the ships can
only travel at about 20 miles or 31 kilometers
per hour.
Compare that to a Nimitz-class aircraft carrier
which, at almost twice the size, can travel
at 35 miles or 56 kilometers per hour.
If there was, say, a disaster in Sri Lanka,
it would take five days to get the ship into
full operating status, and then 20 to sail
all the way to the Indian Ocean.
By that time, nearly a month after the disaster,
the trauma phase of medical response would
be largely done.
This is likely a reason why a majority of
the ships’ deployments have been near the
US—in the Americas.
Of those, many have been long-planned humanitarian
missions to provide advanced healthcare to
areas without it.
These are, of course, incredibly impactful
for those they serve, but overall, the ships
just aren’t designed for super-fast response
to critical crises.
The very size that slows it does, however,
have a purpose.
Beyond just allowing for a massive capacity,
the ships are stable enough that, even when
floating, it is possible to conduct most types
of surgery in their 12 operating rooms.
There are exceptions—the floating platform
doesn’t allow for open-heart surgery—but
still, the possibility of conducting advanced
medical interventions at sea is impressive.
There are, however, more issues related to
the origins of the ships.
You see, hospitals are quite tricky facilities
to design.
Small and subtle differences can mean the
difference between life and death, and so
the accumulated experience of hundreds of
years has resulted in explicit knowledge on
how hospitals should be built.
One of the myriad principles is that movement
bottlenecks should be minimized.
That leads to features like wide hallways
and doors, but it also means that, as much
as possible, the use of elevators should be
avoided.
The technique to achieve that is, of course,
to make hospitals wider.
You want as much as possible on the same floor
so that there is as little need as possible
to put patients in elevators when transferring
them from one area to the other.
If, for example, a patient takes a turn for
the worse and needs to be rushed to an operating
room, the 90 seconds waiting for and riding
the elevator can mean the difference between
life and death.
This also has an implication on overall hospital
efficiency.
For example, you ideally want radiology rather
close to and on the same floor as the emergency
room since many patients often need x-ray
imaging right when they present to the ER.
The further away it is, the longer it takes
to get a patient to and from there, and then
the longer they spend in the ER department
overall, and the more beds are needed to serve
the same number of patients in the ER.
These principles are all why hospitals tend
to be wide.
Even in places with incredible density and
high real-estate costs like New York, most
hospitals are wider than they are tall.
In all, hospital design is a puzzle where
all the elements that patients most commonly
are transferred between need to be as close,
in travel time, to each other.
Looking at the outside of the USNS Mercy and
Comfort, you would think that they would properly
follow this principle of width before height,
but unfortunately, during their conversion,
legacies of their past lives were left behind.
You see, tanker ships, on the inside, are
not just one big empty hull filled with oil.
They were when they first emerged, many years
ago, but the issue there was that, with a
slight tilt forwards, backwards, or to a side,
oil would start sloshing to that side, which
leads to more weight on that side, which leads
to more tilt, which leads to more oil sloshing,
and so on and so forth until a ship capsized.
That was clearly an issue, but one easily
solved by creating bulkheads both laterally
and longitudinally so that oil couldn’t
slosh around.
The problem, though, is the these were left
in the Comfort and Mercy.
There are no doors between bulkheads on the
lower floors.
Therefore, if one needs to get a patient from
here to here, they have to be brought up an
elevator, across the top deck, and back down
again.
This leads to huge movement issues, making
the ship’s effectiveness as a hospital more
limited.
That’s just one large example, but there
are plenty of other smaller issues with the
ship designs that make them less effective
than they could be.
They are, after all, nearly 50 years old,
and the Navy was already starting to plan
their retirement decades ago.
Their original cost, including both the ship
purchase and conversion, was $275 million
each, which may seem like a lot, but this
is the same Navy that spends billions on single
destroyers.
A couple hundred million is a bargain for
a ship of this size and, yearly, its operating
costs are rather insignificant in the context
of the Navy.
It’s the kind of asset that makes sense
to keep around just in case it becomes useful,
as it does every once in a while when disaster
strikes in the US or abroad, but also one
that the US is likely to be unwilling to invest
in upgrading.
A dedicated, purpose-built hospital ship of
this size could be an enormous step up from
these, but when given the choice between a
new destroyer or a new hospital ship, the
Navy’s going to pick the destroyer.
It’s for that reason why the Comfort and
Mercy have stayed in service for so long,
and why they’re likely to stay in service
until the very last day possible.
They may not be of enormous use in the Navy’s
eyes, but to the thousands that they treat,
they’re a symbol of hope in tough times
and, until they’re incapable of helping
anyone, they serve a crucial purpose.
Skills aren’t only things that help you
in work and school.
They also can help you have fun or manage
stress.
Some of the classes available on Skillshare
help you do just that.
For example, their class on creating the perfect
grilled cheese or selecting the perfect houseplant
or drawing as self discovery—these aren’t
going to get you a job, but they will help
you entertain yourself.
Of course Skillshare can also help you with
the hard skills, but this goes to demonstrate
that if there’s something you want to learn,
Skillshare can help you with it.
Skillshare is built for creative, curious
people—those that enjoy learning something
new, no matter if they’re a beginner or
expert—and if that sounds like you, then
you should absolutely sign up.
By being one of the first 1000 to go to skl.sh/wendover9,
you’ll get two months free, and you’ll
be supporting Wendover Productions.